seeing a lot of people say that  moisturizers with spf aren't as good as  sunscreen and that's just not true  moisturizers with spf and sunscreen are  the same from a formulation standpoint  sunscreens have a lotion base containing  oils that can act as exclusives and  emollients and they usually have a  humectant moisturizer too in them like  glycerin it's entirely a marketing  decision whether a product gets called a  moisturizer with spf or a sunscreen  australia which has some of the  strictest sunscreen regulations in the  world actually singles out moisturizers  with spf greater than 15 as an example  of a not sunscreen product that's  treated legally the same as sunscreen